why do so few people trust Klaus Schwab
in World economic Forum like why is it
that they're in every single
conversation of people these guys want
to control you they want to make
decisions for you they want you to eat
insects there's no way they said you got
to eat insects they would never say such
a thing they would never say you
shouldn't eat meat or you know us will
no longer be a superpower why would they
say such a thing U.S pays into World
economic form so we decided to
domesticate it we realized this man
Claus Schwab is actually a modern-day
Nostradamus he knows how to predict
crisis from happening he's got that kind
of gift we'll talk about that we'll talk
about how much money they've raised
their expenses on an annual basis you'll
see who was invited to be a young Global
leader three names wait to see what
Tulsi musk and Vivek said to World
economic Forum we'll cover that as well
and a bunch of other things having said
that stay tuned we're going to study
World economic forum and Cloud show up
in this episode so give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel if you get
value out of this video Let's Get Right
into this Cloud Schwab founded World
economic Forum in 1971 as a
not-for-profit foundation it is
headquarter in Geneva Switzerland it was
originally called the European
management forum and initially his Focus
was in the meetings on how European
firms could catch up with the U.S
management practices this is their
mission statement engage business
political academic and other leaders of
society to shape Global Regional and
Industry agendas mission is committed to
improve the state of the world so far
sounds pretty good they made a
prediction on what they think is going
to happen in 2038 to them which I think
it's important for you to know here's
some of the predictions number one you
own nothing and you'll be happy by the
way this is from their website this is a
video they produced number two the U.S
won't be the world's leading superpower
instead a handful of countries will
dominate number three you won't die
waiting for an organ donor instead we
won't transplant organs we'll print new
ones very interesting number four you'll
eat much less meat if you like meat
you're kind of screwed here number five
a billion people will be displaced by
climate change will have to do a better
job at welcoming and integrating
refugees sounds very Noble but who knows
what that means if the world's only
going to be ran by five countries
there's not a superpower so can they
just choose to say this 10 million will
be moving to your state this 8 million
is going here they get to choose that if
that's what integration means number six
polluters will have to pay to emit
carbon dioxide there will be a global
price on carbon this will help make
fossil fuels history number seven you
could be preparing to go to Mars oh my
God can you imagine how they're trying
to sell the people around the world
scientists will have worked out how to
keep you healthy in space science will
work out how to keep you healthy in
Space the start of a journey to find
alien life number eight Western values
will have been tested to the breaking
point checks and balances that underpin
our democracies must not be forgotten
how do you feel right now are you like
watching this thing there's nobody this
is true let me go Google this myself go
ahead and do it pause the video check it
for yourself and then come back and
you'll see this is what they're telling
you if they're selling you a dream man
this is awesome I can't wait to live
this life well then follow whatever
they're telling you but if this is a
nightmare type of a situation coming
from their mouth to you you may want to
investigate these guys before we see
them as experts and honorable leaders
that we subscribe to whatever they tell
us to do now here's their objectives I
want to read to you from their website
your
stay tuned let me just read it to you
it's not going to sound real but let me
read it to you so like I've been the
financial industry since 9 11 the day
before 9 11 and I've owned stocks bonds
mutual funds real estate crypto gold you
name it I've owned it but the one thing
that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my net worth in
gold that I have access to in case of
many different things a few facts you
need to know about gold number one the
gold market cap is 11.8 trillion dollars
since 2000 the compound annual growth
rate for gold has been 9.24 and during
times of high inflation three percent
plus has been 15.35 percent now those
are just some numbers for you but
there's some other benefits to add gold
to your portfolio number one hedge
against inflation number two results
showed recently that 93 of central banks
are working on a cbdc so this means what
that could be a manipulated currency
that they own if you own gold it's a
non-duplicatable asset you're now
hedging against cbdc taking place number
three a potential cyber threat if it
happens you don't have access to your
money you don't have access to your
account where you have access to your
hard physical gold number four is
anonymous no one knows you have that
gold and last but not least
diversification that's why we chose to
work with our new sponsor American
Hartford gold if you have retirement
funds that you cannot afford to lose
American Heart for gold will ship
physical gold or silver directly to your
door also if you have retirement funds
that you can't afford to lose now is the
time to call American Hartford gold a
precious metal dealer you can trust they
have the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A plus from the Better Business Bureau
tell them I sent you and they'll send
you up to five thousand dollars worth of
free silver on your first order so click
on the link in the description or call
866-939-6984 again
866-939-6984 globalism Net Zero
reimagining capitalism this is being
said by people who have never ran a
business since before Klaus Schwab is
not a businessman he pays himself a
million dollars a year but he's not a
businessman he's hurting small
businesses like you and I who run
businesses he's not a fan of you he
wants to control you because he thinks
he knows what's best for you slowing
population growth they're not saying
depopulation it's more like saying
slowing population growth it's a little
bit more gentle and Yuval Harari who is
their number two guy at World economic
Forum said the following about you
humans are now hackable animals are you
a hackable animal that's what the number
two guide World economic Forum thinks
about you and me how do you feel about
that is this exciting like we're
learning about an organization that
you're just excited about right so how
does this thing operate what do they do
this organization meets annually in
Davos Switzerland it convenes Regional
Summits industry Summits and other
events around the world the revenue
streams is funded through world's most
significant business entities who joined
the Forum as members and partners in
order to participate approximately
thousand corporations hold memberships
in World economic Forum including Google
Apple Microsoft Amazon and many others
which we'll take a look at membership
and partnership fees varies from uh
sixty thousand dollars annually to uh
595 000 annual according to Bloomberg
and in 2022 there were approximately two
thousand delegates including Al Gore
John Kerry Christine Lagarde Jen
stoltenberg Ursula vanderlen Henry
Kissinger George Soros and many other
high-profile names you may be curious
about the financial statement what kind
of money they're making what kind of
money they're paying out this is what it
looks like in the last six years in 2017
to have total expenses of 278 million
dollars of which they paid 108 million
dollars to staff and 170 million to
office and activity and that led all the
way down to today 2022
383 million dollars in expenses 130
million to staff 252 million to office
and activity 383 it's a good number what
they're spending every year and they're
able to get a lot of money from a lot of
big names I'll read you some of the
companies right now but you may ask why
are companies partnering with World
economic Forum here's what McKinsey said
on what the benefits are to join World
economic Forum WF partners with many
International organizations and
corporations to run projects addressing
global concerns this year collaborations
are focused on pursuing a net zero
pathway nurturing resilience reimagining
globalization and supporting diversity
equity and inclusion which is Dei in
every part of society do you see some
touches of ESG in there I kind of read
that the Dei equals ESG CEI corporate
Equity index score all that stuff that's
kind of what you're hearing from one of
the biggest consulting firms in the
world McKenzie now if you're wondering
what other companies are part of let's
read through some of the list here that
you may know Accenture AIG Alibaba
Allianz Amazon Bain and Company Bank of
America Barclays Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation BlackRock Boston Consulting
Group BP Bridgewater Associates Chevron
Cisco City the Coca-Cola Company Dell
Technologies Deloitte Deutsche Bank DHL
group ey which is Ernst young Goldman
Google Hewlett Packard HP HSBC Huawei
IBM Intel Johnson and Johnson JPMorgan
and Chase KPMG Lazar MasterCard McKinsey
and Company meta Microsoft Mitsubishi
Morgan Stanley Nestle open Society
Foundation George Soros palantir PayPal
PepsiCo Pfizer PWC Procter Gamble
Qualcomm Royal Phillips Salesforce
Sequoia capital cements Sony SNP Global
Swiss free Uber Technologies UBS Verizon
Visa Volkswagen Volvo Zurich Insurance
Group see how many different Industries
massive companies multi-multi Billion
Auto Behemoth companies are members and
they're coming together what's the whole
purpose of this it's a globalism to
control what the smaller people don't
get to do they make the decision that's
best for you kind of gets you thinking a
little bit right makes you want to be a
little bit skeptical but let's go a
little bit deeper what are some of the
initiatives the first one which is kind
of interesting remember earlier I said
Nostradamus check this out the great
reset you want to know what book Klaus
Schwab wrote and when here's a question
for you I'm right now about to launch my
business book that's going to come out
here soon called choose your enemies
wisely do you know how long we've been
working on this book a little over two
years how long do you think it takes to
write your book publish it release it to
people even if you're fast what would
you say a year 18 months maybe you're
super fast it's what six months watch
the book this guy wrote the book's title
is covid-19 the great reset written by
Klaus Schwab ready for the release date
July 2020.
do you know when kovitz shut down
America and it was a mess NHL MB all
that stuff mid-march
you either wrote the book published a
book drafted the book printed the book
in three four months or you kind of
timed it very well how did you know
see what I'm saying kind of makes you
think don't it am I the only crazy one
are you kind of processing that as well
so when people say the timing's a little
off you got to give those people a
little bit of credibility for
questioning the timing what a perfect
timing of a book watch how he speaks
when he's talking about this great
reason you ready tell me if this sounds
like a welcoming language just tell you
know how people talk to welcoming
language tell me what this sounds like
every country from the United States to
China must participate not shell not
ought to must participate in every
industry from oil and gas to Tech must
be transformed in short we need a great
reset of capitalism who are you to know
what we need from a man who's never ran
a business before all you do is raise
money getting Europe to compete against
us because U.S was your enemy somehow
you fooled U.S to come and join WF now
we must do what you want us to do since
when does the world run this way but
wait for this famous line You'll own
nothing and be happy do you own anything
are you happy do you live in a house you
own is this your phone are you willing
to close your own do you like owning
stuff that's yours that you worked hard
for well according to him you ain't
gonna know none of that stuff but you're
still going to be very happy number two
is another book that he wrote he called
it the fourth Industrial Revolution in
this book he describes the convergence
of digital biological and physical
Innovations it encompasses advances such
as artificial intelligence robotics The
Internet of Things autonomous vehicles
predictive health care and digital
identities focus on societal
implications of these rapid
technological changes and the four
revolutions he talks about is the first
one is 1784 steam water mechanical
production equipment 1870 is the second
one division of labor electricity and
mass production 1969 Electronics I.T
automated production and cyber physical
systems and the third one stakeholder
capitalism which is one of his favorites
by the way stakeholder capitalism is a
system which corporations are oriented
to serve the interests of all their
stakeholders sounds Noble okay among the
key stakeholders are customer suppliers
employees shareholders and local
communities again sounds Noble if it's
by choice not by force under the system
a company's purpose is to create
long-term value and not to maximize
profits and enhance shareholder value at
the cost of other stakeholders since our
companies go out of business and last
but not least World economic Forum has
been a proponent of this model
emphasizing a move away from the
short-term shareholder value to
long-term sustainable growth and
responsibility once again if he knew how
to do this why didn't you start your own
company and do this yourself why Force
others to do something that you've never
done before you've never started a
company these are valid questions to ask
which I would love to meet Cloud Schwab
and do an interview with them to ask
these respectful questions that many
others have for someone like Klaus and
number four is Young global leaders
program which he launched in 2004 it
seeks to identify and nurture the next
generation of leaders recognize Isis
individuals under 40 for their
professional accomplishments commitment
to society and potential to contribute
to shaping the future 1400 members
alumni of 120 nationalities includes
Civic and business innovators
entrepreneurs technology Pioneers
Educators activists artists journalists
and many more this list includes and I'm
going to read some more names for you
are you ready Putin's one Trudeau's
another one Merkel macron Newsom yarden
and many others and by the way they
divided by different Industries let me
read you some other names that you may
know people to Chelsea Clinton I know
her husband is a is a you know a friend
okay a friendly podcast guest we've had
before Nikki Haley Adam kinzinger
Jonathan Soros son of George Soros
Lauren Summers Paul Krugman in a media
space Fareed Zakaria Anderson Cooper
Sanjay Gupta Andrew Ross Sorkin Thomas
Friedman George Stephanopoulos Lachlan
Murdoch Maria bartiroma now here's for
technology and social media Bill Gates
Steve Ballmer Bezos Sergey Brin and
Larry Page Eric Smith Peter Thiel Mark
Zuckerberg Sheryl Sandberg from Great
Britain Tony Blair Nile Ferguson Charles
Allen remember how I told you Tulsi musk
and Vivek all three were nominated but
they said not interested we're okay you
don't need to recognize us thank you but
thank you so again you pick and choose
you may be watching the same I want to
get nominated for this great you can go
get nominated for this guy but you may
say I don't really want to get nominated
but here's what some people who said
good things about him said and here's
what some people said bad things about
world economic Forum let me read both of
them to you number one Al Gore boiling
the oceans creating these atmospheric
rivers and the rain bombs and sucking
the moisture out of the land and
creating the droughts and melting the
ice and raising the sea level and
causing these waves of climate refugees
it's kind of like
is that an encouraging message if you
listen to this you almost want to go to
space to leave her don't just like enter
the world here and that's positive to
say good things about world economic
form but let me give you some of the
other side here's what Rhonda Santa said
the elites and the Davos World economic
Forum want to run everything and turn
everybody else on the planet into a surf
or peasant Tucker said the world
economic Forum seems to exist to destroy
National economies musk rips World
economic Forum unelected world
government and I'll read this one to you
for somebody from the labor party Swiss
labor party liberal left Progressive
like an antifa of Swiss here's what
Alexander and lean had to say about this
the main yearly meeting of CEOs of
transnational corporations and
bourgeoisie politicians from leading
capitalist countries who discuss without
any Democratic legitimacy nor any
control from the people questions that
concern everyone the countries of the
global South have nothing to say about
decisions that will harm them this kind
of form shows the fundamentally
anti-democratic oligarchic nature of our
system the protection of the environment
is also a major discussion of world
economic Forum however every year one
thousand private jets fly to Davos which
is equal to the pollution emitted by 300
000 cars altogether man they really care
about this climate change stuff and
protecting it for you and I so how
excited are you right now are you still
saying well I've had this little crazy
come on man you guys are overselling it
no problem you ever had insects have you
ever eaten insects well I want to read
this to you from their website just a
year ago February 2022 five reasons why
eating insects could reduce climate
change not not private jets
not private jets even Mario's laughing
insects could reduce climate change
number one edible insects can produce
equivalent amounts of quality protein
when compared to animals how awesome is
that insects require less care and
upkeep than livestock number three we're
actually running out of protein number
four insects are part of virtuous Eco
cycle why don't you be virtuous and eat
more insects and number five you can
start small and work your way up
just you know why would you not want to
eat insects isn't this Noble doesn't it
get you emotional thinking about how
much they care about us who cares about
you as much as they do who else makes
you eat insects to live a healthier life
Eco who else makes you do that noble
people at World economic Forum look I
got to tell you I I like talking to
everybody and I give everybody the
benefit of doubt I'm telling you I would
love to talk to Claus show up sincerely
I would love to fly out to Geneva to sit
down and talk to this guy wherever he
lives I'd love to go to his place and
have a conversation with them Klaus this
doesn't make any sense there is no
selling the dream everything is force
must you better all of this that's just
not the American way and I feel you
don't like the American way because the
American way allows for us to choose
free to choose if somebody wants to eat
insects go for it put mayonnaise on it
put mustard hot sauce whatever you want
to do but you can't say in fool American
people saying eating insects is good for
you so if you want watching this saying
I don't know man I've heard a lot about
world economic Forum I'm just verifying
everything you're saying Pat this kind
of stuff is adding that's kind of weird
insect cashless Society carbon tax
social credit score you want to have a
social credit score on how you voted on
how you eat you got like your FICA
allows you to get a loan to buy a house
now imagine your social credit score
which way you gonna vote hey do you
notice how you want to know we can't
give you this I want more insects nope
you voted this way we're not going to
give you do you want to have fewer
insects can you imagine like how crazy
it is to think about like they dictate
what you get based on your social credit
score so solution today I was talking to
Russell Brand on his podcast and he was
asking about all the stuff that's going
on with you know corporate Elites and
these capitalists that are doing what
they're doing there's a very big
difference between capitalists that are
running their small businesses and
growing and creating jobs these guys
controlled by World economic form of
controlling so what can you do about it
number one be aware talk about it
discuss it with your Congressman discuss
with your family publicize it do your
own research educate everybody around
you and choose what companies you do
business with the way you get to vote in
capitalism which is awesome is if you
don't like what some company does go
support another one that supports the
values that you're okay with that's how
you get to vote when it comes down to
capitalism that's why some companies go
out of business who refuse to listen to
who the customer who's the customer you
you have the power we have the power on
how we vote with these businesses by the
way we spend our money okay so if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel I
forgot you think and share it with other
people but I got another video I want
you to watch if you've never seen the
video we made about ESG click here to
watch it if you've never seen a video we
made about George Soros click here to
watch it take care everybody
foreign
[Music]